[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
las campañas de vacunación en américa
latina para ello me acompañan ya en este
estudio dos compañeras periodistas una
maría ospina de la redacción américa
latina' de recibir bienvenida anamaría
gracias carlos paloma varón periodista
en la relación brasileña bienvenida
paloma ángeles y en dúplex nos acompaña
desde reino unido la profesora marta
cohen experta pediatra y patólogo desde
el hospital de sheffield señora cohen
buenos días
buenos días cómo están la desigualdad en
la vacunación en américa latina' hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues américa latina' superado el
millón de muertos y los 18 millones de
casos positivos de kobe la pandemia no
ha hecho más que profundizar la matriz
de desigualdad la economía ha caído un 8
por ciento en 2020 y enviado a la
pobreza a decenas de millones de
personas mucho más expuestas a contraer
el virus y con menos oportunidades de
acceder a un test oa una cama en un
hospital en este escenario aparecen las
campañas de vacunación con de nuevo la
desigualdad como gran característica en
el acceso a las vacunas vamos a tratar
este asunto y en primera plana antes
repasemos algunas portadas el comercio
en perú china dice que todo está listo
para el envío de vacunas clarín en
argentina pensaban tener en enero 5
millones de vacunas pero sólo habrá 520
mil rusia confirmó demoras en la
estrella en la entrega de su vacuna
sputnik en brásil diario 'o globo'
los gobiernos de 15 estados brasileños
intentan comprar vacunas una situación
dice
el rotativo brasileño de auténtica
contrarreloj bueno a paso lento y un
comienzo irregular según los países
podríamos resumir así que están siendo
las campañas de vacunación en américa
latina'
por supuesto carlos porque cada país en
américa latina' socialmente tiene una
convulsión política también muy
particular de cada país y son
territorios heterogéneos que hace que la
logística por ejemplo entrega vacunas
dependiendo del territorio no sea la
misma y esto dificulta pues que se
avance de manera igual en todo el
continente brasil ahora mismo es el
segundo país paloma con mayor número de
fallecidos después de eeuu la gestión de
bolsonaro está siendo muy criticada y la
campaña de vacunación es de nuevo una
controversia más no si es parte de una
gestión que fue elegida la peor gestión
del mundo por un estudio australiano
entonces ya era esperado que por la
vacunación también el brasil de estar en
un retraso y no hay tampoco hay
transparencia cada estado de brasil
intenta hacer por sí mismo señora que
estamos viendo estos días en plena
actualidad hablando hablando compañera
paloma de retrasos los retrasos
precisamente de las farmacéuticas con
las dosis y por ejemplo aquí aquí un
gran pulso en europa entre astrazéneca
con la unión europea que está hablando
hasta incluso de requisar las vacunas
que se produzcan dentro de los límites
de la unión europea no sé si estamos
viendo un mejor postor vamos en toda
esta situación no sé qué valoraciones
bento de este pulso que están teniendo
las farmacéuticas con la unión europea
que se puede que puede llegar también a
américa latina' claro bueno esto es
tristísimo esto es algo que en realidad
comenzó hace varios meses cuando los
laboratorios comenzaron a vender vacunas
por adelantado y necesitaban por ejemplo
en el mes de marzo el reino unido- pago
a oxford cien millones de euros
la unión europea le pagó 300 casi 300
millones de euros a doctor astrazéneca
entonces los países desarrollados que
tienen el 14 por ciento de la población
mundial compraron por adelantado más del
51 por ciento de las vacunas de manera
que canadá tiene 9 por habitante eeuu
tiene 7 el reino unido tiene 6 por
habitantes europa toda la unión europea
australia y japón entonces qué pasa se
vendió de más se produce de menos se
dijo que se iba a producir más de lo que
en realidad hay capacidad para producir
entonces ahora empezó la pulseada que
está yo creo ayer cuando el oxford le
dijo a la unión europea no voy a poder
dar todas las vacunas solamente un 25
por ciento de lo que en realidad había
vendido en la unión europea' furiosa
dijo bueno nosotros nos vamos a dejar
salir ni facer ni
en laboratorio astrazéneca de aquí en
las vacunas no van a salir y no
solamente lo hace para el reino unido
sino lo hace también para todo el mundo
es decir primero tiene que estar en la
unión europea los países de la unión
europea
van a instituir todo un papeleo
formularios burocracias para que primero
se complete la cuota de la unión europea
y lo que quede salga para el resto del
mundo por supuesto países como en mi
caso argentina no tienen tienen comprado
22 millones y medio de oxford
astrazéneca tienen comprado sputnik pero
no tienen contratos con otros
laboratorios están haciendo contratos
con china pero bueno las vacunas es
mucho menor lo que se ha vendido en
latinoamérica y me hablemos de áfrica
áfrica ni siquiera en tres cuentas
todavía luego vamos a hablar y luego
vamos a hablar también de kóvacs pero
este asunto del que hablamos de los
cursos de las farmacéuticas está ligado
a otro en países como colombia se ha
criticado la falta de transparencia del
gobierno de bambú que en las
negociaciones de las vacunas no ha sido
por supuesto un caso aislado entienden
estas críticas
colombia es un país que actualmente
estaba muy criticado por las situaciones
de corrupción si bien no es el país más
corrupto del mundo y transparente
internacional en el último estudio que
mostró pues se ubica en el puesto 92 lo
que es preocupante por otras situaciones
que no tienen necesariamente que ver con
la salud pero esto tiene una repercusión
y hace que el pueblo pues de manera
general no confíe en lo que el gobierno
va anunciando ahora se critica mucho la
falta de transparencia de negociación si
bien el gobierno explica que no puede
indicar toda la información comercial de
negociación pero el ciudadanía si
necesita saber por lo menos cómo será
ese esquema para decirte esta semana se
aceleró el proceso allá en colombia el
27 enero ya empezaron a anunciar cómo
sería con las farmacéuticas pfizer donde
ya se avanzó en negociación mucho más
estarán también en el programa kóvacs
astrazéneca y jensen que es la vacuna de
johnson y johnson para las localidades
más remotas donde es mucho más difícil
conservar así que ya hay un esquema de
vacunación sin embargo pues la gente
tiene dudas en saber si serán realmente
para la ciudadanía y no se va a perder
algún dinero o algunas vacunas en el
camino vamos
intentando retratar un poco una
radiografía que lógicamente tiene sus
especificidades según qué país sea en el
caso de brasil
paloma bolsonaro avala que el sector
privado compre las vacunas de forma
autónoma se trata de implicar al sector
privado ante la ineficacia de la campaña
de vacunación se trata primero es un
gobierno de negacionistas desde el
principio negaba que el virus fuera
importante que fuera mucho más
contagioso que una gripe y no ha hecho
una estrategia no para kóvacs pues por
ejemplo podía
obtener entonces para la mitad de la
población me ha elegido detener justo
diez por ciento entonces fueron escojas
mal hechas desde el principio y esto de
meter el sector privado en la cuenta es
yo lo veo como es para quitarle la
responsabilidad del gobierno federal
como no tenemos dos es para todos así
que vamos a dar el sector privado esta
competencia de comprar las dosis pero lo
que pasa es que no se respetan las
prioridades para vacunación es un
acuerdo colectivo así que es importante
de primero que los primeros en recibir
la vacuna sean los prioritarios
disminuirá la presión hospitalaria así
que si los empleados de empresas reciben
antes eso no va a disminuir porque no
son ellos que van al hospital cuando
están de los casos más graves así que no
puede dar a la salud pública eso no
ayuda no es no es una eficaz polémicas
de gente que se cuela en asuntos de
vacunación también no estamos teniendo
en europa en mi país en españa está
viendo varios casos ya incluso de
políticos que hay corrupción incluso en
este tema de las vacunas hasta la
técnica con algunos laboratorios y han
dicho que no es posible la venta a
empresas y que sólo son posibles los
acuerdos con países a diferencia de
europa en américa latina cada campaña de
vacunación tiene características propias
méxico fue el primer país y usa un combo
entre facer astrazéneca el programa
kóvacs y la vacuna china y otros países
que han apostado por sputnik las rusas
el caso de argentina el país de la
doctora marta cohen y el caso singular
de cuba que apuesta por una vacuna
propia señora que en la negociación
conjunta de la unión europea contrasta
con la situación de américa latina-
haciendo diferentes estrategias no
muchos planes de vacuna
al mismo tiempo
y bueno en argentina él se intentó con
fases pero por razones de la cadena de
frío entiendo y de la negociación de
cómo se planteaba no se firmó el
contrato se ha firmado un contrato con
oxford astrazéneca para 22 millones y
medio de dosis para el mes de marzo pero
bueno ahora con lo que pasa con oxford
astrazéneca la unión europea
probablemente puede ser demorado pienso
yo está el contacto con el sputnik 5 la
sputnik que como le dicen este ya se han
entregado como usted decía 520 mil dosis
ha habido que ir a buscarlos y por
supuesto no no son los prometidos que
cuando en el mes de agosto dijeron que
iban a llegar tantos millones para el
medio de noviembre y yo dije que era
generar falsas expectativas salían los
titulares de los diarios diciendo que
contradecía el ministro pero era la
realidad son falsas expectativas y bueno
y ahora está el contrato que se está
organizando con el gobierno chino
marta en su país en argentina se han
existido debates sobre la eficacia de la
vacuna rusa ha pasado en más sitios le
pregunto también como científica tanto
la russa
la china están justificadas las dudas
que a veces existen sobre estas vacunas
bueno la vacuna del instituto gamma ley
a la vacuna sputnik es una vacuna que lo
que yo siempre digo es seguramente va a
ser una vacuna que va a funcionar y
sobre todo muy similar al de oxford
tiene interesantemente usar dos vectores
diferentes para despertar mejor
inmunidad pero se ha aprobado en el mes
de agosto con 196 voluntarios sanos en
militares del ejército ruso ahí nomás en
agosto el primer ministro putin firmó la
aprobación y garantizando 24 meses de
inmunidad como si eso fuera algo que se
puede comprar entonces la fase 3 que
todas las vacunas de oxford modernas y
de faisal lo han terminado esta vacuna
de sputnik la empezó en septiembre y la
está terminando recién para el medio
fines del mes de abril por lo tanto está
en etapa experimental y ahí es donde no
solamente se estaría probando de
emergencia que es terminada la fase 3
sino en este caso de súper emergencia
que es con la fase 2 con 196
voluntarios sanos que es la única
evidencia escrita en el publicado en
lancet y ahí el debate que sigue la be
dieta política aquí en argentina hemos
conocido que unos 280 millones de dosis
de vacunas contra el cob y 19 llegarán
américa latina este año a través del
programa kóvacs la iniciativa
internacional para llevar a esta masiva
campaña de inmunización a todos los
países supongo que para ciertos países
de la región es muy importante no la
llegada de cova sobre todo pienso en los
centroamericanos honduras el salvador de
peces que dependen mucho de que hace
parte de este programa como los países
más vulnerables y que pueden necesitar
la vacuna es importante porque estos
países no están preparados para hacer un
pago anticipado o incluso hacerlo a
largo tiempo de esta vacuna si lo vendan
a un precio comercial el hecho que la
organización mundial de la salud decida
digamos encarar este programa kóvacs
para hacer que sea de una manera más
igualitaria pues se inscriben en esa
idea de que es una pandemia que es un
problema mundial y que los países más
ricos deben dar la mano a los países con
más necesidades en este caso los países
centroamericanos y también notar ahora
que hablamos de argentina que en el foro
económico mundial de davos
el presidente alberto fernández dijo
este jueves que la vacuna sea un bien
público global es decir es el llamado a
que lo que hace kóvacs ahora que todos
puedan tener un acceso de manera
igualitaria y que a los países pobres
pues no se les deje siendo países pobres
incluso para una vacunación que puede
ayudar al planeta entero vamos a hacer
una breve pausa y a la vuelta les quiero
preguntar en todos los asuntos por la
aceptación social en américa latina' de
las vacunas hasta ahora
[Música]
ah
la sociedad hondureña se mantiene
dividida a raíz de la decisión del
congreso nacional de blindar la ley
contra el aborto esta decisión ha sido
tomada de buena manera por
organizaciones ligadas a la comunidad
religiosa mientras tanto las
organizaciones feministas y defensoras
de los derechos humanos ha lanzado su
voz de protesta ellas se pedían la
modificación de esta ley y la
despenalización del aborto en tres casos
excepcionales malformación del feto
embarazo producto de violaciones y
cuando la vida de la madre está en
peligro sin embargo estas observaciones
no fueron tomadas en cuenta por el
parlamento hondureño por otro lado la
organización de las naciones unidas la
onu ha pedido al parlamento una
reconsideración a esta decisión tomada
consideran que honduras es uno de los
países que tiene las más elevadas tasas
de natalidad y de embarazos en
adolescentes 1 de cada 3 alumbramientos
adolescente menor de 19 años
[Música]
la aprobación del aborto de la vecina
argentina que fue seguida de cerca por
muchos grupos feministas en chile- ha
reactivado un proyecto de ley que venía
durmiendo desde hace más de dos años y
medio en el congreso chileno la comisión
de mujer y equidad de género formado por
diputadas y de mayoría opositora está
escuchando a las partes en un debate que
se prevé arduo y extenso en el tiempo y
para el que no hay un plazo determinado
en caso de que decidiera aprobar la idea
de despenalizar el aborto en el país
esta idea de legislar todavía debería de
ser aprobada tanto por la cámara de
diputados- como por el senado esta
comisión evalúa que entre 30.000 y
150.000 mujeres abortan clandestinamente
en chile- todos los años un país en el
que el aborto terapeútico en tres
causales por violación riesgo de vida
del feto o riesgo de vida de la madre
todavía se aprueba in extremis en el
2017 y en la práctica enfrenta muchas
trabas tanto de objeción de conciencia
de los facultativos como de maltrato
velado entre otras para aquellas mujeres
que quieren ejercer legítimamente su
derecho
[Música]
en méxico a diferencia de otros países
no se impulsará desde el ejecutivo
federal la despenalización del aborto el
presidente lópez obrador no sólo ha
dejado en claro que no enviará al
congreso una iniciativa al respecto sino
que incluso ha causado polémica al
sugerir que se lleve a cabo una consulta
popular sobre el tema la secretaria de
gobernacion oiga sánchez cordero que se
ha expresado a favor de que sea una
decisión de las mujeres precisó que los
derechos no se pueden someter a consulta
y que en todo caso se discutiría el tipo
penal y es que en el país entre enero y
diciembre de 2020 se tuvo un registro de
633 abortos catalogados como delitos del
fuero común únicamente la ciudad de
mexico y oaxaca tienen legalizada la
interrupción del embarazo antes de las
12 semanas de gestación desde la
perspectiva de salud pública han
disminuido las muertes por abortos
clandestinos sin embargo el tema sigue
siendo una de las principales causas de
grupos feministas sobre todo desde el
punto de vista del derecho a decidir
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana de radio
francia internacional y de france 24
esta semana hablando de las campañas de
vacunación en américa latina lo hacemos
con mis compañeras ana maría ospina
paloma varón y con la doctora marta
cohen desde el reino unido bueno a la
pandemia también se ha convertido en
brasil en un campo de batalla político
entre bolsonaro y los gobernadores de
los estados especialmente creo paloma
que es combativo es el gobernador de sao
paulo joao doria quien se atribuye el
éxito de la llegada al país de la vacuna
china sinovac hay mucha carrera política
en toda esta campaña de vacunación en
brasil no especialmente
ahora y era un antiguo aliado político
de persona no estaba con él por la
campaña por la presidencial pero es
verdad que cuando vos cuando empecé se
empieza la pandemia en brasil y
bolsonaro es el presidente negacionista
y los gobernadores de cada estado
tuvieron se aislarán sobre todo el área
de sao paulo que es el estado más rico
de brasil económicamente
entonces claro él también tiene
proyectos políticos para 2022 quiere ser
presidente y san pablo como el estado
más rico que tiene el instituto butantán
el instituto que junto con los en el
back de china han producido la vacuna
chino brasileña entonces empezó a la
vacunación en brasil antes que el resto
del país el 17 de enero para él fue
claro para su imagen fue muy eso fue muy
bueno para los brasileños fue una dosis
de esperanza después de que somos el
país el segundo país más denotado del
mundo pero evolucionar clasificó eso
como una estrategia de marketing y
después la vacunación con empezó en los
otros estados pero es verdad sí que son
pablo como tiene más vencimiento en
pesquisa en científica fue el primero
estado
pero si claro todo todo desde el
principio la pandemia en brasil fue
politizada entonces los partidarios de
persona no no no utilizaban mascarillas
no hacían el confinamiento recuerda
mucho la situación de eeuu si así como
en eeuu
también fue tan politizado que los
republicanos no utilizaban mascarillas y
los demócratas sí y eso en brasilia por
el confinamiento por ejemplo después
vamos a hablar de manadas imaginas de
amazonas
bolsonaro fue cuando el gobernador de
amazonas en el siempre haya dicho que
debían combinarse después d
de las fiestas de navidad
contra uno debemos confirmar si se mira
fríamente llama mucho la atención que el
uso de gestos barrera o de medidas como
llevar una mascarilla se pueda politizar
y llegar y tener una carga ideológica a
mí me resulta realmente impresionante
pero bueno señora cohen usted
precisamente que está en reino unido hay
expertos que hablan de las variantes
como la británica como otra pandemia
dentro de la pandemia como una especie
de segunda pandemia este rebrote de
cepas y variantes podríamos decir que
sigue el curso habitual de un virus sí
absolutamente es más el virus está
coronavirus está mutando menos que lo
que lo hace el virus de la gripe que
todos los años va mutando y todos los
años necesitamos una vacuna diferente lo
que pasa que es es una consecuencia de
nosotros mismos
cuanto más nosotros nos contagiamos
cuanto más transmisión del virus hay más
el virus tiene que adaptarse al pasar de
una persona a otra de un huésped a otro
y para adaptarse muta entonces ahí hay
muchísimos miles de mutaciones pero
han surgido nuevas variantes cuando esas
mutaciones son significativas como el
caso de la variante de sudáfrica de la
variante del reino unido- la variante de
brasil que son han modificado la
glicoproteína s que está en la espiga de
la corona del virus y lo han hecho más
fácilmente que puede ingresar más
fácilmente al organismo entonces para mí
esto ya es una tercera ola no es cierto
porque la segunda ola que comenzó en
septiembre había sido una mutación que
surgió en el noreste de españa pero ya
esta es una nueva mutación y se ha
acelerado muchísimo al punto que yo me
pregunto si las medidas de confinamiento
o sea de distanciamiento social con el
barbijo la higiene de manos y el
distanciamiento son eficaces de la misma
manera porque este virus puede contagiar
70 veces más rápido y más fácil pero
sabemos que los barbijos por ejemplo
protegen un 67 por ciento eso era con la
variante anterior a lo mejor con esta
variante protegen - por eso estamos
viendo algunos gobiernos como el francés
que están prohibiendo ahora
mascarillas caseras mascarillas
artesanal es decir estamos yendo hacia
una a un refuerzo de esos gestos barrera
no le quería hacer la pregunta del
millón doctor doctora cohen a la que
ahora mismo hacemos
planteamos en todos los medios de
comunicación que las vacunas están
preparadas le habremos hecho mil veces
esta pregunta para afrontar estas
variantes bueno y de acuerdo a la
variante británica hasta ahora sí
o sea hasta ahora sí es estudios hechos
con modernos y estudios hechos con facer
utilizando el plasma de voluntarios y
exponiéndolos al nuevos virus al nueva
lente el virus lo pudieron neutralizar
sin embargo en la variante de sudáfrica
que estimo yo es más peligrosa porque
estudios hechos con modernas encontraron
que un sexto solamente protege es decir
que para esta nueva variante la
protección ha bajado a un sexto o se ha
bajado seis veces lo cual esto hace que
moderna va a tener que modificar y bueno
france se va a tener casi lo mismo y va
a tardar unas semanas unos meses
no más de un uno o dos meses creo yo
pero si eso eso es muy grave y con
respecto quería hacerte un comentario
están los con respecto al uso de barbijo
es la mascarilla quirúrgica que están
imponiendo europa para mí eso tiene un
doble mensaje también y puede ser muy
peligroso porque la gente de recursos
humildes tenía una mascarilla de tela
que lavaba todos los días la gente que
tiene eso también bajos recursos no va a
poder comprar mascarillas quirúrgicas
para reemplazarlas al menos dos veces al
día como deberíamos estar haciendo por
lo tanto eso es un riesgo en sí mismo
para mí por supuesto
volvemos a los temas de vacunación a las
campañas de diferentes ritmos en américa
latina en adquisiciones si hay un país
que destaca por encima de todos es
chileno que destaca por encima del resto
de los países de la región en cuanto a
las dosis que ya ha adquirido no chile
tiene la ventaja que es un país que se
considera en vía de desarrollo es decir
que tiene un nivel económico un poco más
alto que el resto de países de la región
y eso sin duda se ve reflejado la última
adquisición la hizo este jueves
es la vacuna china y además empieza la
próxima semana una campaña masiva de
vacunación es decir a partir del próximo
miércoles millones de personas van a ser
vacunados rápidamente de acuerdo a la
edad y la prioridad si son trabajos de
la salud o no pero se va a acelerar lo
que promete el gobierno de una manera
muy importante
quiero rápidamente hablar del tema de
perú porque es una característica
particular de lo que sucede en américa
latina que tiene que ver con la
convulsión política recordemos que en
noviembre tuvo tres presidentes en dos
semanas tres cambios de gabinete y esto
impidió que las negociaciones avanzarán
rápidamente porque cada cambio implicaba
un nuevo grupo de negociación y esto ha
hecho pues que sea uno de los últimos
países en anunciar esta campaña
finalmente en las últimas 24 horas
anunció que comprará a la banca la
vacuna china y ya está listo para ir un
avión busca beijing para poderla buscar
pues y llevarlas a perú y luego en
lugares que están sufriendo situaciones
realmente alarmantes en medio de esta
pandemia uno de ellos es el estado de
amazonas paloma cuéntanos por qué hasta
el ministro de salud brasileño está
siendo investigado por todo lo que está
ocurriendo en allí en amazonas y el
ministro de la salud eduardo para suelo
y está siendo investigado por un pobre
inc
administrativa por este caso porque ya
sabía desde diciembre desde noviembre
según los especialistas y los médicos
demandados ya sabía que el sistema iba a
entrar en colapso y no ha hecho nada ha
hecho así que hay propuestas propias de
eso porque hayan sido comunicado de la
luz el sistema público de manuel se ha
comunicado es el gobierno federal en
nada ha sido hecho entonces cuando llegó
a finales de diciembre y los primeros
días de enero como continúa ahora con el
colapso del sistema con falta de oxígeno
con un médico para 40 pacientes graves
eso ya era esperado era la crónica de
una tragedia anunciada no fue una
sorpresa y por eso está siendo
investigado pues todo eso es parte de la
estrategia del gobierno bolsonaro de
negar no no
y como amazonas en un estado más aislado
de los grandes centros es volar es
importante aunque menos si eso se pasará
en río y soy malo yo pienso que sería
una tragedia nacional pero como es
amazonas dejaron llegar hasta el último
es una verdadera tragedia es si estaba
siendo investigado
hablemos en los últimos minutos del
programa del escepticismo y de la
aceptación social de las vacunas porque
lo hemos hecho en otras ocasiones
hablando de europa también lo queremos
hacer en los casos de américa latina'
esta es una cuestión un poco de países
ricos no así tienen la impresión de que
este asunto tiene que ver con poder
permitirse hablar de ello no poderse
permitirse de hablar de desconfianza y
que en lugares donde ni siquiera estoy
pensando en haití no sé si es ni
siquiera un tema del que se pueda llegar
a hablar como lo ve nana pienso que la
mayoría de las personas en américa
latina' si se quieren vacunar es un
deseo porque saben que si no lo hacen
pues el comercio va a seguir hacia abajo
y necesitan salir a comer a vender estoy
hablando de los trabajadores informales
y también el hecho que se ha hablado que
era como él la respuesta milagro para
salir de la pandemia sin embargo las
redes sociales estas cadenas de
desprestigio de las vacunas sin importar
el origen pues también hace que algunas
personas lo piensen dos veces antes de
vacunarse pero pienso que de manera
general hay un interés grande en américa
latina porque por vacunar no sé
vacunarse lo más rápido posible
de usted señora cohen
sí absolutamente por un lado lo que pasa
en argentina y bueno en el resto del
mundo es que la gente más joven tiende a
ser menos inclinado a vacunarse a
desconfiar más que se ha hecho muy
rápidamente y eso es porque se deja no
escucha las noticias no escucha los
informes del gobierno no escucha las
noticias serias se escucha y sigue las
redes y en las redes hay muchas fake
news no es cierto y por otro lado la
gente también menos educada y por ahí
confía menos y en el caso específico de
argentina está gran desconfianza que
hablábamos antes y que tiene un
basamento político pero en general la
gente de más edad de mediana edad para
arriba y más tiene más tendencia a
vacunarse y por lo menos alrededor del
68 por ciento en el mundo van a decir
que se van a abandonar además por
ejemplo en el caso español que yo lo
conozco en las residencias de ancianos
casi nadie está diciendo que no a la
vacuna lo cual quiere decir un índice de
aceptación social que desde luego es muy
superior ya nos estamos quedando sin
tiempo pero como dice la doctora cohen
en muchas de sus entrevistas
la vacuna no es la panacea hay que
seguir con los gestos barreras y hay que
seguir con los test no señora cohen y si
mira te quiero decir para tus seguidores
en el arroba de de marta coin en
facebook instagram yo siempre hablo de
los tres pilares un pilar es la vacuna
la vacuna simplemente puede darnos una
esperanza porque nos va a disminuir la
posibilidad de tener una enfermedad
grave o morir no pero no necesariamente
va a evitar que nos infectivos que nos
contagiamos y tengamos una enfermedad
leve pero con trajimos a otro que puede
tener una enfermedad grave el otro pilar
es la responsabilidad individual el
distanciamiento social la higiene de
manos el uso de máscaras y esa
responsabilidad individual tiene que
tener una gran aceptación social la
sociedad lo tiene que aceptar me quedo
hace un tiempo pero nos quedamos con ese
mensaje es que nos quedamos ya sin
tiempo de señora cohen pero nos quedamos
con ese mensaje las vacunas no son la
panacea para solucionar esta epidemia y
hay que seguir con los otros dos pilares
con los tests y con los gestos barreras
muchísimas gracias a la extracción un
placer compartir este tiempo con ustedes
la próxima semana volvemos aquí en
primera plana